[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what's up everybody i'm mari takahashi
and i'm jeff keeley welcome to netflix
geeked week yeah the sequel right the
sequel second year doing them geeked
week 2022 baby uh it's great to be back
here with you jeff i know it was just a
year ago i feel like we were at summer
game fest with our good buddy rahul just
talking about it that's right netflix
gaming shows this year though we've also
got netflix games and i'm thrilled to
have netflix as part of the summer game
fest this year so shout out to everyone
watching on the game awards channel
right now and also uh to everyone
co-streaming on twitch that's right it's
not just about me it's about everyone in
the community who's here for the big
breaking news that's right all week long
netflix has been dropping trailers and
big news about series and movies but
today it is all about the thing that we
love it's all about games baby that's
right maureen you know last year when we
were here it was just shows based on
games but today we'll also be announcing
some games based on shows you guys with
us plus some well-loved mobile games are
coming to netflix and some brand new
games from developers like devolver
digital it's so awesome to see netflix
in the gaming business so shows games
everything you want about netflix and
games right here today which is a lot to
unpack this is the very first time we
get to cover netflix games and this
incredible lineup there's so much
there's so much jeff so are we gonna
start with a game or a show that's a
good question we're announcing a brand
new series based on a massively popular
video game which doesn't give you a lot
but i'm sure you'll tell us what i know
it could just be about anything but it
is a world exclusive trailer you know i
love those
check this out
so
[Music]
[Music]
we're in
dragon age absolution
this is exciting because everyone's been
awaiting the next dragon age game i
think we announced it at the game awards
like three four years ago and while we
wait for the game now we get an
incredible new show and it looks amazing
i'm curious about how it fits together
but it's called dragon age absolution
yeah i played inquisition and i remember
i mean there's so much lore when it
comes to dragon age right and so i'm
really excited where like you said where
we're going to be plopped in and how all
of that lore is going to be kind of
spoon fed to me because i feel like it's
it's just the best pieces of it and
we're going to get all of those and it's
been i think quite a while since we've
had new dragon age lore i mean it's been
a long time since we've had a game even
though one is in development so it's
great that we're getting this ahead of i
think the game even i mean with dragon
ages elves and mages and qunari and it's
it's really cool to expand on the dragon
age series absolutely and it looks great
that was a nice surprise i didn't even
know that was coming so great news and
that's not all here's a closer look at
the brand new poster
for the show that we are premiering here
on geek tweet check it out
who is she i know yeah that's what's
cool is i love now that i think game
companies and netflix everyone are
thinking about this stuff holistically
and kind of introducing like lore and
characters sometimes in an anime or a
comic book
before the game hopefully it somehow
ties in but yeah i have no idea who
hopefully it's a new character that
maybe we'll get to meet in the game but
first of the series i want to know what
class she is she looks like she she
might be an elf but who knows what's her
name uh yeah what's her name what's her
backstory these are all the things we're
probably not gonna get answers to today
but i am uh very excited to learn more
and i got to say that the series looks
incredible yeah i love the animation
style too
everyone don't miss the rich lore in
world building of dragon age absolution
that's right we are gonna keep our eyes
on that that was a nice surprise a big
way to kick off geeked week gaming and
if you want to rewatch that gorgeous
trailer we just put it up on twitter at
netflix geeked this next series is sure
to be a are you ready yeah hit oh
yes we're talking about
tekken bloodline
i gotta say when i was a kid growing up
in canada i loved playing tekken in the
arcades and then on playstation this is
such a classic fighting franchise it's
been a few years since we've had a new
tekken but now this iconic fighting game
franchise is now in anime coming to
netflix and is sure to please old and
new fans alike yeah i mean again the
animation style is so interesting today
we have a special treat for tekken fans
a message from creator katsuhiro hirada
i'm so so excited to see it let's roll
it
foreign
that was so cool harada i mean
that's mr tekken so you have him that's
what i love about all this stuff that
netflix does is harada is directly
involved as you can see in building this
out and partnering with netflix to make
a a tekken
story which yeah again i wouldn't have
guessed a tekken anime would be on the
uh on the menu but it looks incredible i
mean like you said it's for the fans
from the source itself which makes it so
so much better cool fighting of course i
think that's all going to be implemented
but it sounds like there's going to be
so much more depth to the story we're
going to really get to see jyn and his
mother june's sort of relationship and
what all of that means for the entire
series itself very exciting i'm just
saying i'm sure there's going to be some
incredible action as we would expect and
it is so cool to see haradasan good to
see you my friend uh hope he's also
working on another tekken game but he is
an icon in the fighting game community
and a badass in his own right a
legendary personality
and of course legendary sunglasses
legendary outfits harada always shows up
with style yeah where can we get the
harada glasses huh
i should say we should end the show in
our her out of glass we should be sure
to head over to twitter for more tekken
news at netflix geek to stay on top of
it and for all things anime you know
what to do smash that follow button
on twitter for netflix anime
so if you didn't know over the last year
netflix has started including a bunch of
great mobile games as part of your
membership that's right this is a brand
new thing netflix introduced late last
year and there are no ads no micro
transactions and a huge variety of games
that are constantly being updated for
everyone who's a netflix subscriber no
additional cost here's a taste of the
games you can find right now
[Music]
[Music]
i want that as my theme song i love it
it's so good
like it's so diverse and i feel like my
netflix homepage in general looks that
diverse too with the stuff that i watch
and to see that reflected in the games
that's really cool to start we have a
few based off of some of the most
popular netflix series our first one is
coming to you straight from the fold
there are no others like us and there
never will be
you have no idea
how much larger a role you have to play
[Music]
that's right shadow and bone is getting
a game y'all shadow and bone destinies
is a narrative rpg with roguelike
elements based on the beloved show based
on lee bardugo's books in this game you
play as your favorite characters and
journey across the world of the greece
reverse in a narrative adventure to
fulfill your destinies
along the way you'll need to make
decisions that will determine the course
of your journey it's being created by
chimera entertainment and we actually
learned on monday that the production
has officially wrapped on season two of
the show so
shadow and bone fans we are eating good
this year whether you're a darcelina
stan or at molina supremacy
whatever that means be sure to follow
netflix geeked on instagram
okay so jeff um you were saying yeah
that there's a wide variety of games on
netflix which is true and i
got a look at your second game today and
um yeah i think this is exactly for you
they finally made a game for your
personal favorite netflix show nailed it
jeff i'm very excited what too hot to
handle
coming from developer nanobit based off
the hit that's right hit netflix reality
show
it is you're right mari too hot to
handle the game see finally jeff they've
been listening to you twitch chat i'm
sure is just i can't even imagine what's
going on now in the chat guys but here
you go too hard to handle this is
actually a real game it is coming to
netflix that's right and just like too
hot to handle the series expect the game
to feature lots of um innuendos and fun
plot twists and of course
romance
i'm just mesmerized watching the
dialogue go out here select select your
outfit oh my god uh-huh the game follows
the tv show rules and the player's goal
is to find the best partner by going
through episodes and making their own
decisions
basically their own season how fun is
that she's talking about how she sells
real estate i'm reading all the dialogue
here as we go on
she blushes how about you gorgeous i
didn't catch your name maybe we should
just re we should just read the b-roll
up to uh
anyways i'm definitely not getting the
prize money i don't think but uh i'll
i'll try
yeah again out of all the games that
will be announced today i will tell you
walking in this door this morning i did
not expect to see a too hot to handle
game all right well the show is
absolutely
insane if you haven't seen it so if you
want to dive in while you wait for the
game too hot to handle is on netflix the
first three seasons right now okay jeff
i don't know about we recovered from
that murray
yeah no i don't think there's ever
recovering from that
season four season four
get this guy on the show
say all right well so now we gotta
where do we go from there right we're
pivoting we are pivoting straight to
some badass action okay um i don't know
what about you but uh my netflix list is
this conglomeration of the too hot to
handles you know the reality tv shows
and then also like epic awesome badass
stories so um yeah of course we're gonna
be talking about that next okay well
we've got some epic stories and even
more epic games like our next one la
casa de papel
this show is a global phenomenon and now
netflix has partnered with the developer
killasoft to put you behind the mask oh
intriguing this is an adventure game
featuring an original standalone story
set in the la casa de papel universe
it's got a cool cel-shaded look i wasn't
expecting that yeah are you ready to
sneak by cameras crawl through vents
hack security systems and silently knock
out your enemies to pull off the world's
biggest heist metal gear papal that's
right
this is a huge international phenomenon
this show um and it's so cool again it's
like this is a real adaptation that i
think it's a very stylized take on this
game right i was like joking in like
metal gear it's like it's obviously it's
a very action oriented heist sort of
game and this is you know feels very
strategic too and how you go through it
so it looks like they've got safe
cracking and everything that's right
safe cracking lock picking mini games
shooting sequences and um of course the
heist going awry
anything can happen that's right i don't
know how they do it so quietly i just
feel like i would make something like
every game those gonna have some kind of
vent right yeah you got to have the vent
system crawl there's all of this and
much much more in the game based on la
casa de papel
now speaking of classic netflix shows
over the past few years we all remember
when the queen's gambit inspired a chess
revolution that's right everyone was
watching that show and then everyone was
playing chess
[Music]
chess isn't always competitive
jess can also be
beautiful
now you can enter beth harmon's world
because there's a new game coming out
from developer ripstone
inspired by the queen's gambit series
that's right and it's not just a chess
board we have the first ever look at the
trailer for the game let's check it out
[Music]
so
[Music]
this game serves as a love letter to the
series you can really see it with the
aesthetics already you can play
competitors online like we just
mentioned or you can play against
characters from the series in beautiful
settings that's probably how we would
play right not online but just ah just
beautiful relaxing game of chess you can
learn chess with mr scheible compete
with borgov or challenge beth to matches
speaking of lovely locations in the park
lovely let's take a look at all these
locations
you can play in beth's house as her
career grows
of course yeah best house that's the way
to do it also uh apparently you can go
to the orphanage where beth learned how
to play chess fun fact and uh how about
las vegas because that's where she
ultimately faced her test a little vegas
chess game at the bar sure yeah and plus
there's tons of puzzles and challenges
to keep your skills nice and sharp check
checkmate check it out if you want more
info on how to play the queen's gambit
check out netflix geeked on instagram
oh i'm excited for this next one oh my
god last year we had so much fun
talking about this and now it's back
that's right next up we have a show
based on a game based on some old-timey
cartoons if that gives you a little bit
of a hint and it's a
knockout
[Music]
oh shut up
the cuphead show oh my god this is this
is honestly one of my favorite shows yes
on netflix i love the game the new uh
dlc delicious last course is actually
coming out later this month we just
showed some stuff off the summer game
fest for that but this show is so fun
because the characters actually have
voices cuphead is always getting mugman
into trouble and it's just it's so
delightful and i love that they're
little snackable episodes they're like
10 minutes long they're just i have so
much fun watching and the there's
nostalgia in the way that it is animated
of course but it's also fresh um gosh it
is so good and the music is so good oh
yeah i i know it's like
it brings so much more to the cuphead
lore when you play delicious last course
i think it's gonna mean that much more
to you now because we've watched these
episodes the thing also is that cuphead
is a very difficult game so i kind of
like that you can just watch this show
and not have to worry about dying every
15 seconds true true but uh the same
amount of screaming as me playing the
game dreams of joy though lots of joy
and laughter yes now if you guys love
the cuphead show like me and like mari
well
get ready to double down
check this out
gosh fellas i'm sorry i got you tossed
in the house the slammer the crowbar
hotel the stoney lonesome the convict
condo the old hoover dubai
i'm here for the soul let's make it
snappy fat chance
now let's scream and catch that picture
show we're shoving off
who's the host with the most you are
your handsome devil spice your tongue or
be sore they'll bite it for you
well you can bite it or i can bite it
but either way it's gonna get bit
let me introduce you to some friends
favorite couple of hot tomatoes mum's
the word it's a secret it goes nothing
[Music]
ah
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Music]
there we go august 19th i think that's
an announcement of the cuphead show and
i love that miss chalice was in that
clip because she's the new playable
character in the dlc that's coming out
in a couple weeks and and we were left
off with season one being like what else
happens with her what's gonna happen oh
my goodness yeah and we saw some return
characters in there as well
um yeah the voices are so good i think
that like those characters
you play the game and you you don't
really think about what they sound like
in real life and then when you when i s
last year we first met the characters
and we heard their voice i'm like it's
just so perfect it's exactly how you
want them to sound they have so much fun
with each other and yeah the fact that
we got the first season earlier this
year and now the next batch of episodes
coming in august uh yeah i'm so excited
it's so authentic as you said like this
is exactly what i want netflix to be
doing more of is adding lore to these
gaming worlds and cuphead itself is such
an amazing series so yeah very exciting
and if you're anything like us and
you're craving some more throwback
animation old-timey music truly just
demented adventures the cuphead show is
streaming right now on netflix with more
episodes on the way this summer that's
right august all right that's that's one
of the biggest announcements of this
show for me and stick around because
later today the cast and showrunners are
doing a table read for a brand new
episode of the cuphead show right here
on geektweek so fun all i want to hear
is more of roll the dice
netflix has been partnering with some of
the best indie devs out there and we're
going to give you an exclusive look at
three new titles all right first up
i mentioned earlier indie games this is
one that i'm very very excited about
it's called lucky luna and it comes from
snowman who you may know as uh the
company behind games like altos odyssey
and skate city ah let's see what they've
got this is a beautiful original brand
new game for netflix check it out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so perfect and this is what i want more
from netflix is completely original
games looks tons of fun has that
old-school feel to it yeah that 8-bit
vibe i'm very very excited this is going
to be coming to netflix and that we got
to announce it yeah and a little bit
more about it it is a journey written in
the stars hidden dungeons mythical
temples mysteries of the past that all
kind of qualifies
any game to be on my list of something i
want to play this story is inspired by a
japanese folk tale called the tale of
the bamboo cutter
over a thousand years later it's a game
which is so awesome my dad used to talk
talk to me about this story it was like
a battle story yeah i'm assuming it's
the princess who
is part of the moon like she's one of
the moon people who have been who who
came to earth and she was found in a
bamboo by the bamboo cutter wow this is
all p i'm piecing it together now it's a
beautiful you're like an expert on the
bamboo cutter
well i don't know
it's i'm an expert only if my dad said
the story right and if i was listening
correctly as a kid he wouldn't lead you
a straight yeah i love though he said
this is something that's not like
there's already an anime of this on
netflix and now they're making a game
like this is in a completely original
experience um and it's a vertical
platformer without a jump button keep
that in mind so you're swiping to move
luna as she plunges deeper and deeper
through ancient temples and lost ruins
which is a genius way to adapt
the usual console kind of side-scrolling
gameplay it's got a story mode special
challenge rooms and an expansive world
but you have to stay focused to avoid
traps dodge enemies and collect pearls
that's what all those little white
things are gotcha an endless mode has
players competing on leaderboards to
collect the most pearls or see who makes
it the furthest in each of the game's
various levels lucky luna
very excited to announce this and it's
coming this summer only on netflix
exclusive independent game from an
acclaimed developer as i said i want to
see more of this from netflix and i'm
very excited that we got to announce
this and that people get to play it this
summer
have you ever wished you could explore
your dreams and memories no
never yeah it's kind of terrible what
about your nightmares
yes yes
desta the memories between is a
turn-based strategy game that's a mix of
into the breach
hades inception
and dodgeball those are four things i
would not think necessarily fit together
yeah no especially the last one yeah
hades dodge ball inception yeah what are
we talking about well in this you
overcome broken relationships and a
tragic family event all through the
medium of a surreal and exciting ball
game let's take a look
[Music]
since i've been home
i've had such vivid dreams
memories of people in places i've
struggled to return to
i'm searching every night
trying to understand
those words left unsaid stand in my way
but i think i found a way through
[Music]
let's see how far it takes us
[Music]
this comes from a really acclaimed
developer in london us too uh dan gray
is one of the guys that i know him well
visited that studio and these guys have
done a lot of really acclaimed
independent games and here's again a
brand new game which as we heard in the
description it's just like unlike
anything else out there
desta the memories between i'm a sucker
for isometric uh viewpoints in games and
just like you said really unexpected
things that's mashed together and you
said isometric these guys did monument
valley which was such a classic
indie game had that cool you know
everyone remembers that game a couple
years ago in the sequels and now they've
gone on to do a bunch of other really
interesting unique games this is another
one which is you know fully original
story um made by an acclaimed mini
developer and coming to netflix desta
the memories between has a roguelike
structure so the enemies and the
abilities change from run to run so it's
kind of infinitely replayable in that
way be sure to check out this game when
it launches later this year
all right i feel like indie game cred
does not get any better than this one
jeff oh wow you're setting up something
pretty big here oh yeah all right well
let's take a look at some games that are
coming to netflix from the one and only
devolver digital devolver has an
incredible eye for stylish exciting
games across all genres they absolutely
do they always have fun crazy
unexpected games as you said and now we
have not one not two but three games
coming to netflix from devolver first up
it is rain's three kingdoms the original
reigns took off as a game that could be
described as tinder for monarchs
i'll go with that you run your own
kingdom making tough decisions that have
rewards and consequences meeting other
characters who can change your destiny
with merely a swipe i mean isn't that
what you're doing with tinder there you
go
also coming from devolver we have tara
nill the strategy city building game
with an emphasis on the climate crisis
this is nice to see right yeah
i mean taranelle it's your job to turn a
barren wasteland into an ecological
paradise with flora fauna wind turbines
and wait for it
water pumps water pumps we love our
water pumps each piece of land you turn
into a lush paradise will give you
points well that's that's just lovely
isn't it yeah it is i mean warms my
heart and once you've successfully saved
the environment
thank you you turn the remaining
buildings into an airship to leave the
beautiful wilds
to nature oh my gosh
that's altruistic i feel like i feel
like we're kind of spoiling the game
aren't we well i don't know i mean it's
a lofty goal to
get to your airship yeah and then to to
beautify it and then to be like you know
what you're better off without me
airship do you think that's like a big
blimp that you get to take often or do
you think it's like no i'm thinking like
spaceship like spacex rocket probably
more that and it's probably not steam
punky if you've got wind turbines and
things like that
see these are all the things we're gonna
have to find out in tara nail and then
finally from the creator of the
award-winning down well it's
pointy
this is my i think this might be my
favorite name for a video game of the
year so far
point p i mean you just love to say it
point p everyone in chat right now
point p point p point
point p that's right exactly i mean get
ready to dodge adorable baddies and feed
the blue beast yes the blue beast that's
hot on your heels that's all coming in
point p we have the first official look
at point p
big exclusive for you let's check it out
[Music]
[Music]
know that the beast was gonna be so cute
this is a beast is it point p what is
pointy is point p the character do we
think i think point b might be the
character that's like a
character
like it's point p like in a specific
character you think point p is like a
species oh a species look at that look
at that all right i'm like it's unclear
to me who are they all point are they
point ps that's like the plural of a
point i feel like point b must be the
character i mean it's got a hat and
stuff you know it's a it's a it's an
established
pers person knows individual eye that's
point p there's only one point there's
only one point the or is it
i don't know many point p i see feed the
beast though and then it being a cat i
feel like most pet owners would be like
yeah i need to feed the bees there's a
lot of point p we need the point p wiki
can someone start that up right now and
start to figure this out i can tell you
this game i'm sure is gonna be very
addictive the more you play you keep
going higher and higher up in the world
and the game of course gets harder and
harder yep bouncing all over the place
grabbing fruit for the beast across
randomly generated areas filled with
creatures and special abilities plus
puzzle mode and endless mode and even
more it looks absolutely great though
and tons of fun and here's the big
announcement drum roll please
point p is available
right now that's right surprise shadow
drop netflix members around the world
can play it today just open up your
netflix app on your phone and search for
point p to download it and play it right
now the summer game fest sensation point
b
download and play now that's so fun
that's what i love about you know
netflix is the stuff is launching all
the time and their new games constantly
showing up in the app as surprises yep
that's right
to say that dota has taken the gaming
world by storm over the past two decades
is a massive understatement jeff you've
been to the international right i have a
couple times i went to the first
international that was actually in
germany back in the day and then i've
been a couple times up to the
international when they did uh the key
arena
which is now climate pledge up in
seattle and it's it's such a sensation i
love i mean all the amazing teams that
have come a part of it and even last
year we had a couple of uh donut teams
that were nominated at the game awards
from ukraine of all places it's a truly
global game and such a phenomenon
valve's done an amazing job with it so
exciting being in an esports arena my
goodness yeah and dota you know people
love the lore and the characters um and
the game has an absolutely massive fan
base and the lore has been brought to
life in the original series dota
dragon's blood
free
yourself
the old time
has come
[Music]
yep this was when this first season came
out a little while ago and dota fans
were eating good and i understand we
have something special for the dota fans
right now
i believe i've been targeted all right
she's i'm sure there's nothing personal
arrow is headed right in my direction if
i don't release all the details right
now on dota dragon's blood which is set
in a fantasy world of magic and
mysticism the story follows a dragon
knight davion who hunts and slays
dragons to make the world
a safer place is it a safer place if
they're fewer dragons in the world uh
i'm not sure that's necessarily true
right and not if you ask the dragon
exactly i say more a lot we need more
dragons in this world anyways
based on the valve video game dota 2
season 3 of dragon's blood is coming to
netflix on august 11th oh that's
exciting august 11. dota we've got um
lots of cool stuff happening in august
with the cuphead show but right now
we've got point p have you guys finished
your point p download i was gonna say it
is available right now now for something
completely different how about something
as thematically far from dota as
possible something something completely
i don't know adorable are we announcing
point p2 right now point me too
happening right now dominical
yes here's a pallet cleanser guys roll
it
[Music]
you know i have to admit something when
i saw this in the script after we'd done
too hot to handle i'm like wild things
this is the charlie sheen movie amazing
like
completely different like how risque are
we getting like no we're going to wild
things animal adventures all right
yeah i'm a sucker for these types of
games where it looks like it's a match
three and then you beautify your area i
i love these kinds of things look how
cute that elephant is yep now what's
cuter point peter the elephant
oh man pull in the chat guys come on
pull in the chat um no the wild things
are in trouble and they
need your help guys
in wild things you help these cute
beasts restore their wild lands by
playing games and re-beautifying and
restoring their environment to health
and who wouldn't want to help out these
adorable little creatures help them save
all kinds of places lush forests
tropical islands and icy terrains
and they need your help
very soon very soon yeah because you can
download wild things on netflix later
this month i feel like we need a
calendar should we get a i was going to
say point p today later this month wild
thing august dota
august cuphead
then who knows what's beyond that all
right well next up an animated series
based on an absolute gaming
icon that's right we're talking about
sonic prime and we've got some very
exciting news from some of sonic's
friends let's check it out
[Music]
sorry big sorry froggy can't chat gotta
go help our friends
no problem sonic
i know what you're thinking i'm good and
powerful apparently jealous
[Music]
sonic has had a big year he's got a
schedule he's got no time for anyone i
mean
how could you have time when you've got
the movie
the new game frontiers is coming out
later this year and that's the agent on
the phone sonic prime sonic is sonic's a
pretty big deal these days absolutely
sonic prime is the hedgehog you know and
love until an incredible twist thrusts
sonic into a new adventure the new
series features a reinvented cast and
sonic like you've never seen him before
where the fate of the multiverse rests
in his gloved hands
this time sonic's adventure isn't just a
race to save the universe from dr eggman
it's a race to save dun dun dun
his friends honestly i think sonic's
kind of taken his friends for granted if
i have to be honest with you whoo that's
a hot topic i mean how could you take
big the cat or
froggy for granted i mean come on
we're getting into froggy wow we're
getting deep into sonic laura all right
well we're gonna find out what happens
to sonic
froggy and all his other friends when
sonic prime debuts only on netflix
okay so back to the games we debuted
some today based on netflix shows saw
some fresh ideas from brilliant indie
studios i mean what's next jeff i think
we're gonna take a look at a few games
you may recognize that are making their
mobile debut
only on netflix first up here is raji an
ancient epic in this game you play young
raji chosen by the gods to stand against
a demonic invasion her destiny to rescue
her younger brother and face the demon
lord everyone say it together with me
oh yeah see that's the toughest word of
the show
it's gonna be a blast to play coming
from nodding head games later this year
mark that calendar
now let's take a look at another
celebrated indie coming soon to netflix
this is spirit fairer
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
all the steps one takes to
move on
[Music]
that was so much to unpack
it started with like okay cool it's
crafting there's mining there's building
involved oh okay that's like got some 2d
scroller type of elements to it and then
it's like learn to say goodbye
yes death is a theme in this game which
came out a couple years ago on uh on
xbox this developer thunder lotus games
is up in canada uh and it's a really
it's a beautiful game as you said like
there's a lot to unpack there's a lot
deeper than you'd think spirit fair is
the coziest sweetest game about yes
dying now available for the first time
on mobile i never thought i'd ever say
that that's a really good way to
describe it my gosh you play as stella
fairy master to the deceased a spirit
fairer build a boat to explore the world
then befriend and care for spirits
before finally releasing them into the
afterlife
yeah uh there's so much going on as you
said in this game you can spend relaxing
quality time with your spirit passengers
create lasting memories and ultimately
learn as the trailer said how to say
goodbye that's so deep
my gosh it's a beautiful game uh very
thought-provoking and has never been on
mobile before
but now it's going to be there you go
it's such a unique and creative concept
for a game
so no wonder it's been so popular i'm
gonna stop sleeping on it and i'm gonna
i'm gonna play it okay well if you're
looking forward to spirit fair like mari
let us know over on twitter at netflix
geeked
it is so exciting to see all of these
legit mobile games i mean how crazy to
go from mailing dvds to getting video
games on your mobile device i mean what
a glow up netflix has had i know it
makes you think like what's next
yeah what is next well now we're going
to head on over
to walleykia for a very special geeked
week announcement
don't listen to her i have no choice
there's always a choice i'm sorry you
know you kill vampires but i pray for
you i'm so sorry so part of you has died
we are looking for someone called
belmont
castlevania is back can i hear richter
yeah i think you did i mean i feel like
castlevania really was the o.g netflix
gaming show if you guys remember that's
the bar exactly
an incredible franchise we all know and
love from our childhood done so well on
netflix and now castlevania nocturne is
the new castlevania series
from showrunner kevin coldy it'll focus
on richter belmont a descendant of
trevor in sifa in maria renard during
the french revolution castlevania
nocturne is currently in production but
be sure to get all the latest updates on
that new series right over on twitter at
netflix geeked my gosh we're good
how'd it go all right we have covered so
much today mario does that mean we're
like at the end of the show i don't know
don't say it's so pointy
i was gonna say there may be a point be
surprised
yeah there's a ton more coming though
actually that's right hard to believe
but by the end of this year there will
be over 50 different
netflix games so many games i mean games
on top of games on top of games it is so
exciting and here's a taste of
everything else coming
our way
[Applause]
[Music]
good
take one
[Music]
wow it's amazing in a year
how far netflix even happier really how
far netflix has come and i was excited
to see a lot of those indie
announcements today clearly games are
going to be a big part of netflix moving
forward and also gaming series so we had
a a jam-packed day i can't imagine what
geeks week 23 is going to look like if
we're on this kind of clip no
it was a lot today it was and so much to
look forward to as well it was and while
you're waiting for all of the new ones
to drop there are tons of free games for
you to download
right now such as
point p see guys we're driving we're
driving record number of point b
downloads all right well i'm gonna do
that right now because that folks
is our show and that's geeked week
almost they're still almost yeah that's
right don't go anywhere because even
though the debuts are done we're
finishing geeked week with a bang of
course up next the cast and creators of
the cuphead show are doing a table read
of a brand new episode which hasn't even
hit
netflix yet another geeked week
exclusive we're gonna be watching that
for sure and then we have the star of
resident evil live at the twitch gaming
gathering so don't miss that that's
really fun down at summer game fest and
to top it all off back here at noon
pacific
join us for a live episode of the geeks
podcast that's right hosts princess
weeks and tessa netting hi tessa we'll
chop up the biggest news of the week and
everything you might have missed i sure
hope point p is the big headline of that
it better be otherwise we'll have
something to say all right absolutely
all right so don't go anywhere but we're
going somewhere
to download
pointy that's right all right we'll see
you guys
next year geek tweak see ya
it is over 11.
you have freed me
you can't stop this now
[Music]
did you ever wonder
where every great fairy tale begins
where the good become heroes
and the evil
become villains
[Music]
welcome
we've been expecting you
[Music]
what was that
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
we're in
there was a time when sea beasts would
ravage our shores
and no ship was safe on the sea
but those days are over
today valiant warriors battle the beasts
far beyond the horizon
you're jacob holland a weapon against
nature's darkest design and i'm joining
your crew oh no you ain't
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i
yeah i like this kid
we're dropping you off at the nearest
port hunting ship ain't no place for a
kid but you joined the ship when you
were the age
[Music]
look at you now
that's not the same thing isn't it
no
it isn't
the drake's more thick with monsters
monsters don't want to eat us we're not
keeping it but he's so cute
you and i have a different idea of cute
just
don't move
this be going
i see a fire in her
same fire i saw in you
the monsters i can handle
we got it right where we want it
i swore i would do everything in my
power to keep people safe you can be a
hero and still be wrong
the ocean has sent us it's worse
then we'll send it right back
i've always wanted a pet
that's not a pet but i already named it
let me guess
blue
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they said the world would end in 2036
but they were wrong
the world ended a long time ago
umbrella
a company besieged by a scandal is now
trying to reinvent itself
the old umbrella made mistakes the
things we're working on today they're
gonna change the world
[Music]
[Applause]
we have a problem
[Music]
the drug contains the t-virus
the t-virus can make monsters
billions will die
everyone keep your mouth shut
[Music]
[ __ ] it
[Applause]
do not
[Music]
is complicated
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they make new friends
welcome to the content show
[Music]
this is the devil's pitchfork episode
number 108 b where cuphead finds the
devil's pitchfork and uses it to have
fun and wreak havoc inciting the devil's
ire
we're inside the devil's headquarters
his bedroom it's morning
a door opens henchmen enters pushing a
tray with food and a newspaper
the devil is curled up in bed
boss wakey wakey
oh boss you've been here for days come
on get up
look what a beautiful day it is he opens
the curtains souls are being tortured
outside
devil curls back up under the covers
ah i know what'll cheer you up
just listen to these headlines
evasive beetles devastate crops
meteor hurtling towards orphanage
ooh meteor
four horses of the
apocalypse on the loose
what a time to be the devil huh
[Music]
hey there's a review
of you
the devil sits up suddenly interested
what's that oh gimme
once at a rare while a figure commands
our respect summons our fears and
effortlessly tempts us into an unhinged
depravity did you hear that henchmen
unhinged depravity
for a millennia it was clear without
debate who that figure was after a
recent string of
humiliating setbacks however it has
become blatantly apparent that the devil
is losing his touch
a silly caricature of his once powerful
self time to pass the walking stick on
the next contender
it's a pitch [ __ ]
the devil throws the paper into the air
and roasts it with his pitchfork
hey
you know what i'd do if i was you
ah
[Applause]
i take my pitchfork and have some fun
go to the surface torment some souls
blow off some steam
i'm just saying
you are the devil after all
you know henchmen you're right
i am the devil i need to get out there
and be the devil i was born to be
ah
thank you henchman i'm about to make a
lot of people
very miserable
he grandly floats out
that's my boss
back at the cottage it's daytime cuphead
sits with his eyes closed
now can i look
uh not yet
how about now
no no don't wait
[Music]
cuphead removes his hands from his eyes
and sees a homemade tandem bike
[Music]
you mutilated on bikes
it's a present i made our bikes into a
tandem bike and now we can ride our
bikes together
we already did ride bikes together
separately
oh now we can ride our bikes together
[Music]
do we always have to do everything
together
you hate it
[Music]
i should probably try it out before i
judge
great let's go
cup it and mug man speed away on the
tandem bike bug man pedals with glee
cuphead is significantly less enthused
[Music]
exterior the inkwell isles classical
music over the sun beaming down on a
peaceful city the devil poofs in on a
hill
he uses his hail to pop kids balloons
[Laughter]
[Music]
a little old lady sits on a park bench
feeding the pigeons the devil enters
behind her he zaps a pigeon it grows
into a giant mutant pigeon the pigeon
eats the old lady
[Music]
the devil poofs the top of a stop sign
he changes all the stop signs at an
intersection into green go signs the
cars swerve and crash into one another
[Music]
now the devil is in his dragon form
chasing people through the streets
[Applause]
back on the hill later the devil sits on
the top of the hill continually leaning
against a tree in front of him inkwell
city is on fire
lost my touch i think not
the elevator appears henchman steps out
hiya boss so how'd it go
um
it was great i feel like my old wicked
self again
details five what details
very well henchmen
first i tortured some children then i
blew up the elevator closes and
disappears we pull back to reveal the
devil's pitchfork that he forgot is
leaning against a tree meanwhile on a
rule road cuphead leans back and reads a
comic book
you know what mugsy i take it all back
this is some great bite
mugman is doing all the pedal
hey uh
you mind pellet faster i could use a
little breeze back here
a breeze huh
you know what you're a real pain in my
dick
mugman skids to a stop and they see the
devil's pitchfork is leaning against the
tree
is that what i think it is
it can't be
oh but it is
cuphead pops off the bike and moves
towards the pitchfork reaching for it
don't touch it
what if only the devil can use it
[Music]
but
what if anyone can use it
back in the devil's headquarters later
the elevator doors open an upbeat
refresh devil emerges along with
henchmen
the sound of screaming
oh what a delicious day
ah
precious memories just me and my
pitchfork
the devil reaches over but nothing's
there
[Music]
where's my pitchfork
it dawns on him he left it behind we
hardcut to the wooded area tin cans
lined up on a log ready
aim fire
kapow the entire log explodes reveal
cuphead's toppled over from firing the
massive pitchfork
[Music]
are you okay
this thing sure packs a wallop i i think
we'd have more control if we both held
on to it
funny
i thought you didn't want to do
everything together
did i say that
well if it makes you feel any better
there isn't anybody else i'd rather go
around blowing up stuff with
oh
now let's go blow stuff up yeah
and with that we cut to the woods they
run through blowing stuff up having the
time of their lives
[Music]
meanwhile back on the underground the
devil frantically looks for his
pitchfork he looks under his throne
cushions nothing's there
it's not under here
oh it's not back there
where
is it
should i have it with me in the elevator
but i don't know
well look around find it
but
calm down
ah
you calm down well let's retrace our
steps
where did you have it last
well
i mutated some pigeons in the park
and then i went to the zoo and released
all the carnivores
and then i set the city on fire
and then
and
i left it against that tree
we're back in the forest carpet and
milkman explode all the trees in the
forest
while they're writing it the pitchfork
suddenly levitates up into the air
huh oh
this is new carpet and mugman fly off on
the pitchfork as the devil's elevator
appears in the field the devil and
henchmen step out that pitchfork is not
there
oh it was right here i'm sure of it
wow
nice work boss you really
burnt everything up
i didn't do that
which means
someone has my pitchfork
are flying behind the devil far up in
the sky the devil doesn't see them
hey mugsy i wonder what else this thing
can do
well there is something i've always
wanted to try
cut to inside of a very fancy restaurant
mugman uses the pitchfork to twirl a big
bite of spaghetti
this is what you always wanted to try
give me that
cuphead grabs the pitchfork and zaps
around the restaurants we reveal the ham
grows an eyeball on glares at its diner
[Music]
cuphead zap steiner spaghetti they all
come alive now with blinking meatball
eyeballs
across the room the angry ham eyes at
steiner hungary
the ham attacks the diner and latches on
to his face then a spaghetti monster
attacks a horse diner
another spaghetti monster attacks a para
girl
sherman spaghetti springs up and latches
onto his face
sherman's girlfriend doris looks on
offended
so are you going to introduce me to your
little friend covenant mugman watched as
the food continues to attack
terrified diners
uh
maybe we should go cutting outside
carpet and mugman exit casually
mugsy oh boy earlier today when you
mutilated our bikes you did something
nice to me now i want to mutilate
something nice for you we cut to a field
bam bam zap cuphead carves something
with the piss fork while mugman faces
the other direction
can't i look
now not yet
almost there
man takes his hands off his eyes and
stares ahead in shock
patience
cuphead continues to blast away with the
pitchfork bangs the pittsford fire is a
final zap cuphead smiles
he's made a mount rushmore of mugman a
mount
mugman mothball
what do you think
very nice
the devil stands right behind cuphead ah
thanks devil but actually i got
the devil
i believe you have something of mine
hand it over uh
okay
sure uh
sorry
we were just horsing around you know
the devil reaches for it and zap the
pitchfork zaps them
oh wow
sorry
that that was an accident
here
cuphead realizes what he has in his
hands he gives a mischievous smile he
holds out the pitchforks of the devil
again and
[Music]
okay
okay sorry really seriously here you go
[Music]
[Music]
you're doing that on purpose
[Music]
the devil looks at them both rage
building
you think this is funny you think you
have the upper hand just because you
have my pitchfork and your soldiers has
expired
[Music]
uh
expired sold it
mugman marches over between cuphead and
the devil
like white white blackbird hold it stop
everything
did you just say
expired so that
he just said expired so dead
wait wait
let me get this straight
i no longer owe him my soul
and
i have his pitchfork
the humiliation
oh wow
now this is just sad i mean it's it's
not even fun anymore here
you should have this it belongs to you
and
you
you were zapped me
no
i promise
ah
thank you very soon
[Laughter]
the devil gets charred henchmen watches
the scene
god
nervous
confident men continue to laugh
and finally grab my straw
the devil's gone the wind blows
ominously as the devil's voice echoes
through the forest
you have taken something of great value
to me
so i shall take something of great value
to you
[Music]
there's nothing you can take from me
that i care about
an off-screen whoosh cuphead turns and
sees the devil inside his own elevator
and he's got mugman
say goodbye to cuphead
goodbye
[Music]
[Laughter]
slam the elevator door shut it
disappears cuphead is left all alone
completely devastated
mugman
mugsy
yeah this one doesn't end on a happy
note
thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
take one
[Music]
tonight we will achieve what no one has
even attempted we will summon
and imprison
death
[Music]
i give you a coin made from a stone
and i give you a feather
pulled from an angel's wings
as family
desire
destiny
despair
which one have i go
dream
you're gonna need all the help you can
get
[Music]
want to stay in the know about your
favorite netflix shows and films you'll
find news videos interviews and more
onto boom the official netflix site to
help find and fuel your fandom stranger
things the grey man the umbrella academy
and more make peak week last all year on
netflix.com
they said the world would end in 2036.
but they were wrong
the world ended a long time ago
umbrella
a company besieged by a scandal is now
trying to reinvent itself
the old umbrella made mistakes
the things we're working on today
they're gonna change the world
[Music]
[Music]
the drug contains the t-virus
the t-virus can make monsters
billions will die
everyone keep your mouth shut
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
is complicated
[Music]
see
[Music]
here's veggie shack
we're getting the very first trailer for
resident evil
[Music]
[Applause]
netflix geek week 2022 june 6th to 10th
sorry
it's geek week
a long time ago
umbrella
a company besieged by a scandal is now
trying to reinvent itself
the old umbrella made mistakes the
things we're working on today they're
gonna change the world
[Music]
[Applause]
we have a problem
[Music]
the drug contains the t-virus
the t-virus can make monsters
billions will die
everyone keep your mouth shut
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is complicated
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what is up everyone welcome back to the
summer gathering here at twitch gaming i
am sitting here with ella belinsky and
if you do not know this is the voice
behind four spoken and as we just saw
the netflix trailer for resident evil
it is a pleasure to meet you i have so
many questions one i just have to ask
how does it feel to be like immersed in
raccoon city
[Music]
needless to say 2022
2036 post zombie apocalypse
are we good
okay
[Music]
we have a whole band like
a whole band
i don't know how much i'm allowed to ask
i understand there are rules but what
can you tell us about your character and
what you know the role you play
so i play jade wesker oh yeah is this
one not on all right
thank you
so um i play the character of jade
wesker who is the daughter of albert
wesker and she
i'm a wesker baby
[Laughter]
um but yes she is a tenacious very
driven uh character who the one thing i
love about her is that she's not a
superhero she's a scientist
she's a survivalist honestly just trying
to make her way through the zombie
apocalypse and try and figure out a cure
for the t virus
so wait in something like this
i i feel like i know i'm not allowed to
ask your role in the show is to figure
out the cure for the t virus
[Laughter]
so i think naturally when you're in uh
an apocalypse you want a zombie
apocalypse you want to try and figure
out a way to sort of
not get the virus as it were so she's
sort of like dealing with the echoes of
the past the mistakes of the past to try
and sort out the situation
in new racoon city 2036.
now as a wesker how did can you tell us
about lance riddick and the role he's
kind of playing as albert wesker what is
that like albert wesker is he's i mean
he's a game classic you know he's he's
even in even in the film franchise he
lance redick is one of the single most
incredible
actors at being so
intensely terrifying
but still so charming and charismatic at
the same time it's the perfect duality
for the character
well you both have a lot in common being
that you're doing a voice
in for spoken and we just saw lance
riddick in horizon so you know what what
is do you ever talk about that those
things did he ask you what your
experience was doing voiceovers versus
you know his did you talk about your
time in the gaming
um so with that it was the interesting
thing was i actually did the full
performance capture for that character
as well so i wasn't just in the studio
doing the voices i was uh in the full
suit with the dots on my face and the
camera
and we have to talk about this because
this was your first experience but i
also learned you also play games you
don't just do the voiceovers form so do
you want to go do you want to go boot up
again okay let's go
your character is adorable so i feel
like
i feel like it was meant to be but don't
worry because incredible since
shoving them at
[Music]
i've actually brought my little
playstation 5 controller
myself
well one y'all it's very pretty i think
it it for
from a distance it might look white it's
like white in a very print it's like a p
it's um it's a
uh i hyper fixated during the pandas
finally
i feel like at this point
as free as you used to be
you're playing a game let's talk
because this was who came out
is there anything new you can tell
so
yes
one two one two check check check check
check
try this one
that's with our directory
[Music]
just make sure not to hit the switch or
anything like that
microphones everywhere um i was you know
but we had an amazing stunt team as well
who when we didn't have the helmet uh
the um sort of like head cameras on were
able to
perform in these incredible incredibly
because sprays like way she moves her
traversal style is very elegant it's
very futuristic actually so they were
able to sort of incorporate a lot of
that into her movement
well i look forward to seeing it i
appreciate you coming and sitting down i
feel like we're we're literally going
from ari on netflix then we're going to
fall guys we're talking four spoken is
there anything else you want to share
with us since i have you here um yeah i
mean i'm very excited to say that i've
got plenty in the pipeline um and i
think you know fans whether you're new
or to the resident evil franchise are
really going to enjoy you know the new
the new show and fall in love with the
characters
absolutely well i just want to make sure
everyone knows because our mics were
mike
so you know i i want to talk to you
about you know for spoken and
being that you did the voice and you're
doing the performance capture with freya
how does did you find yourself relating
with freya
you know what she is
she was a really great character to play
just from from a career perspective
because
she really is just
a person
thrown izukai style into this new
world and she's sort of on this journey
of her figuring out who she is and
taking on the sort of hero role at the
same time it was like i was figuring out
what was going on in in the studio
so you were both lost and confused and
finding yourself you know one take at a
time i i get you i totally understand
for anyone that may have missed out can
you tell us a little bit about freya in
some of her backstory
so
frey is
from the city of new york and she's in a
lot of trouble when you first meet her
and she's um
she finds herself transported into this
new world which is kind of overridden by
this thing called the break
and at first she's just trying to figure
out her way to get home but the journey
that you end up going on you start
realizing that she has a lot more input
in the well-being
of this
place called atheia than you might
realize
okay so
region-wise because you say new york and
then you say atheist what is the time
frame what what year are we in do we get
that in uh in new york yeah
where is atheia in new york is it new
york new york
it's an it's a new universe we don't
know you have to find that out when you
play the game
see the more you tease for spoke girl
girl indeed the more you tease it the
more i i really need to know so that
means we get to see you everywhere can
you tell us when we can be on the
lookout for netflix is resident evil
absolutely so uh resident evil will be
coming to netflix on july 14th
uh you'll be able to watch the whole
series
and uh four spoken is gonna be landing
on pc and playstation around october 11.
you have a very busy year i i feel bad i
feel like i've ruined
your greatness
now we're just watching the masters of
the game
the the experts on how to do it and how
long i feel like
you took it easy on him which means
you're committed for him into it you
know
all good no pressure
that's very commendable of you to not
upstage them
i'm going to lie today and i'm going to
say absolutely and if you want to say
you are too we're just going to lie
together yep full sense full sun
well what else are you playing you're
not playing fall guys
were you familiar with resident evil
before you joined the show on netflix i
was i was i played the games when i was
younger so that's why like this role is
is really um special to me and i really
wanted to take care of you know how we
approached the entire series i had i was
always mentioning you know xyz that came
up in the script with the liquors and
you've got the cerberus and it's great
when i first saw the liquor i lost my
mind because that was that was one of
those few times usually you don't see
them so i'm like the continuity right
it's it is it is present are you
stunting in resident evil as well a lot
a lot thankfully this is not my first
rodeo in the stunting arena
so there's there's some good there's
some great new exciting things but we
have a four spoken cut scene that we're
gonna show everyone right now let's
check it out
[Music]
so these are the archives
catch
what is this
and who are you i'm the archivist
odin tell me you were clever how do you
not know what a book is no i know what a
book is
you don't look like an archivist you
don't look like a hero
that's because i'm not
i used to be a blacksmith before
built weapons for the very woman that
raided our city
she and i were quite close
she trusted me
and i trusted her
sorry
no matter it was another time
she was another woman
as was i
[Music]
is everybody in this town batshit crazy
okay so
how do you go from a blacksmith to a
librarian archivist
and a smart woman knows when to shift
her purpose for the needs of her people
catch
what is this it's the floor plan of
silas castle
but are you my fairy godmother
name's joe haydee
you're the one that's planning on facing
off with sila
well the name's frey and it sounds like
you don't think i'm up to the task
tantasyla is the strongest and most
formidable of all that hunters
she controlled the army
crushing the weak even without the
weapons that i forged for her
crushing them with her bare hands i'm
beginning to have second thoughts about
this these batty old harridan needs to
shut her mouth you will be doing our
land a great service by killing her
rid us of tantasyla
and the corruption in her realm will
stop spreading
i doubt you'll actually succeed
before you go
i would suggest that you learn all that
you can about the tantus
the archives
full of books about them
definitely not my fairy godmother
everybody i'm back yes it's me chelsea
bites and i'm here with the one the only
jackie please tell the grey people what
you do hi guys
thanks for tuning in i'm jackie senior
brand manager over at capcom user
[Music]
i'm from a lineage thousands of years
old of the best monster hunters to ever
walk the earth
[Music]
even on good days i feel like i still
don't fit in
like everyone else has it all figured
out
oh yeah
that i haven't told anyone of course
you are a legacy vampire made vampires
with love see their reflection in a
mirror
we're hunters
more importantly you're my daughter
which is why we've decided you're ready
for your first kill used to killing
monsters
your body is changing my body but very
soon you are going to have to make your
first kill
hi it's juliette right yeah you're
calling oh cow's good
who are you collide where'd you come
from
[Music]
addicted to lavender how does it feel
you're nothing like the monsters i grew
up hating i just want to live my life
you can't be together it won't work i've
forbidden you from seeing her
we're not supposed to be i know my
feelings for you are real julia and
every legacy in savannah dies tonight
run now
keep your things in your mouth we won't
have a problem we will always have a
problem
i had to choose between you and my
family
i choose my family
what about us
faced everyone monster and human who
tried to come between us
we got this
i'll kill for you
what do you know about the sierra
program
reckless mystery man you guys send in
when you can officially send anyone else
the great man
lloyd
i got an urgent locate and destroy
that could be fun the man's got some
street cred
[Music]
you
hurt i mean my ego's a little bruised
they'll have something they really want
what's your gut it's gonna be my funeral
you're going to next
you want to make an omelet
you got to kill some people
you must be lloyd what gave it away the
trash dash it's just it leans lloyd
i'm about to put a hit so big on your
boy's head
that even his most loyal allies don't
hesitate to drop and hide
every grade a wet team from here to
rachel
will be vying for the prestige of
killing the infamous year six
i can kill anybody
maybe not anybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you've broken everything
your suffering
is almost
at an end
dear billy
i don't know if you can even hear this
ever since you left everything's been
a total disaster
for a while we tried to be happy
normal
i know it's impossible
i relocated you guys far from hawkins
[Music]
because i thought you'd be safe
[Music]
a war is coming
i'm afraid your friends at hawkins are
very much
in the eye of the storm
[Music]
i don't have my powers
i don't know how to say this other than
just to say it
[Music]
without you
[Music]
we can't win this war
[Music]
see on the other side
on the other side
[Music]
i was convinced i was put here for some
other reason
maybe i can still help
even if it's the last thing i do
[Music]
people say hawkins is cursed
they're not
way off
it's time
you
have laws
mama let's go we're late do i have to
your grandson's birthday only happens
once a year so does geek tweak
[Music]
stranger things panel starts in 15.
[Music]
sorry it's geeked week
[Music]
netflix geek week 2022 june 6-10
[Music]
tonight is movie night
in here is the great big world
you can go places your dreams can't
dream up
or see things that give your nightmares
nightmares
[Music]
hallelujah
in here you can make your escape
i already don't like you
right back at you sunshine
[Music]
and here mystery sparks extraordinary
adventure
the real mystery is why everyone's
talking to them
i thought that was my
thing and here you never know where the
road will take you
when you walk on that court you have to
think i am the best guy out there i
don't care if i'm a bronze player
in here the party never stops
[Applause]
oh that's false i got something to do in
the morning so it kind of does
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
are you feeling this kinda you don't
have to i know i'm doing it for me okay
[Music]
in here you can make an incredible
discovery
[Applause]
i feel like a kid again i want to see
something cool
[Music]
and here is the great big world and
every night is movie night
[Applause]
it's just
[Applause]
this isn't your home
what are you talking about this is the
umbrella academy
this is the sparrow academy
cheers
[Music]
when we jumped here we created a time
paradox our little paradox brought forth
the freaking kugelblitz what the hell is
the cougar blitz essentially we're
screwed
[Music]
everybody else could see ben right yeah
and he's a complete [ __ ]
they're all [ __ ]
[ __ ] who can fight
next person to say [ __ ] is getting a
punch to the throat [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
we caused a paradox and that paradox is
swallowing things how long do we have
four maybe five days before the rest of
existence is blitzed not to mention
we've been replaced by a bunch of blobs
and cubes and birds and [ __ ]
your team is good but i don't think
you're better than me
i entered the world twice and you you're
just meeting spandex
dad didn't adopt us as babies but those
babies still existed here so if you ever
see your other selves kill them sleep
with them avoid them the hell is wrong
with you oh come on as if you wouldn't
climb luther mountain
if i kill you do we get our bent back
what the hell did you just say
what are you their mascot
more like their ringer
[Music]
i'm looking for you
spoiler alert
getting ready for a new season of the
umbrella academy you'll find news videos
interviews and more onto doom the
official netflix site to help find and
fuel your fandom from rehashing the
finale to re-watching the latest trailer
find more information than the
commission on netflix.com
[Music]
take one
[Music]
tonight we will achieve what no one was
even attempted we will summon
and imprison
death
[Music]
i give you a coin made from a stone
and i give you a feather
pulled from an angel's wing
i give you the blood
from my veins
desire
destiny
despair
which one have i got
dream
you're gonna need all the help you can
get
[Music]
want to stay in the know about your
favorite netflix shows and films you'll
find news videos interviews and more on
to boom the official netflix site to
help find and fuel your fandom stranger
things the grey man the umbrella academy
and more make peak league last all year
on netflix.com
they said the world would end in 2036
but they were wrong
the world ended a long time ago
umbrella
a company besieged by a scandal is now
trying to reinvent itself
the old umbrella made mistakes
the things we're working on today
they're gonna change the world
[Music]
we have a problem
[Music]
the drug contains the t-virus
the t-virus can make monsters
billions will die
everyone keep your mouth shut
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] it
[Music]
do not resist
please
[Music]
[Music]
here's veggie chefs
we're getting the very first trailer for
resident evil
[Music]
[Applause]
netflix geeked week 2022 june 6th to
10th
sorry
it's geek week
[Music]
i'm from a lineage thousands of years
old of the best monster hunters to ever
walk the earth
[Music]
even on good days i feel like i still
don't fit in
like everyone else has it all figured
out
oh yeah
that i haven't told anyone of course
you said you are a legacy vampire of
made vampires with love see their
reflection in a mirror
we're hunters
more importantly you're my daughter
which is why we've decided you're ready
for your first kill used to killing
monsters
your body is changing my body but very
soon you are going to have to make your
first kill
hi it's juliette right yeah you're
kalaipi oh cow's good
who are you kalai where'd you come from
addicted to lavanya how does it feel
you're nothing like the monsters i grew
up hating i just want to live my life
you can't be together it won't work i've
forbidden you from seeing her
we're not supposed to be i know my
feelings for you are real julia and
every legacy in savannah dies tonight
run now
keep your things in your mouth we won't
have a problem we will always have a
problem
i had to choose between you and my
family
i choose my family
what about us
faced everyone monster
hello geeks i am princess weeks author
youtuber content creator who's obsessed
with anime buffy sailor moon hot tall
women with swords doing gay things
shout out to you shira i'm into all of
it and i'm just so happy to be here with
with me with tessa hey guys i'm tessa
netting i'm an actress content creator
and obsessive bisexual ravenclaw who
loves to discover new fandoms and escape
into fantasy worlds especially if
there's a fictional villain that i can
fall in love with there has yet to be a
villain that she hasn't thought you know
he has a point so we hear the geek
podcast we love villains and we are your
weekly energy boost of the world's
fandoms and stories you love
each week we skim the surface of what's
popular in geek culture then deep dive
into the lore of netflix worlds bigger
than our own today we are coming to you
live fresh relatively out of netflix get
week
2022. we just got five days of
everything good series film animation
stranger things more stranger things and
games oh my goodness five days 79 titles
so much
i am overwhelmed in the best way this is
the best ever like we are going to break
down our favorite parts of the week
right here we watch some trailers with
you guys and like we're gonna do so much
we're gonna we're about to geek out with
you so it's exciting a lot so tessa what
hit hardest for you this week of what we
saw i mean
it was stranger things day i'm just i
have the biggest stranger things hyper
fixation right now it has just taken
over my entire brain and that's all i
can think about so it hit really hard
when they all played d and d together
the interviews when david harbor said he
has you know an addiction to the sims
that was a personal he was peacocking
you he was definitely trying to get
johnny potting you with his his sims
love
and it succeeded because i i couldn't
stop thinking about it or him so what
about you what was your favorite um well
i also dressed for the brand i the
school for good and evil teaser i have
been obsessed with those books since
i was a teenager well not a teacher i
was i was in my 20s it felt like a
teenager when you're a millennial um and
my one of my good friends paige turner
if you're watching this hello we read
the books at barnes noble's cover to
cover when they first came out so i'm
here to see
sophie and agatha do their thing yes oh
my goodness it was amazing getting to be
a part of that panel i know
i'm so jealous it was the best uh for
those of you watching along at home we
want to hear from you so go off in the
chat okay we are going to be responding
throughout the whole thing so we want to
hear from you but please be gentle
be kind be kind to us okay so tessa
let's get into it geek week it is
technically still happening because
we're here we're present we're queer
hello uh so let's jog
our memories and your collective
memories with some of the hottest
trailers of the week
so first
umbrella academy
here we go
[Music]
obsidian every time you go to a spooky
hotel you know something ghostly is
gonna happen i love ghosts yes just like
our ghosts
[Music]
god they're such nerds like wanted to
look
she played host to world leaders
roosevelt gandhi stalin gorbachev i've
never seen so many kids that have middle
child syndrome at once
like all of them have such big middle
child energy
competition it's tragic and i relate
i feel for them
they just want attention and i can give
attention to all of them i will be their
daddy
by society i go with their mommy
daddy and mommy both
i got them all it's perfect and the best
part of it is she's gonna look after us
no questions
i want to go let's go let's do it road
trip gosh obsidian hotel like everyone
in the cast is hot but diego was just
especially like yes
oh everyone is beautiful
perfect elliott looks so good
i love him the best
uh so
are you pumped for umbrella academy i
like this season is going to be so
chaotic the sparrow like siblings versus
siblings it's giving me like x-men
versus avengers it's all the big things
i love a crossover verse
yeah and i just love it like two sets of
middle siblings fighting over
who daddy loves the most it's it's a
story of me relatable very relatable
totally oh i cannot wait i cannot wait
for these new characters and just we
know that it's gonna be chaotic and it's
gonna be the best and i i love allison i
always have and we have been able to see
a little bit more than the average bear
um allison gets what she she is in it's
her season
she's fantastic her and elliot have such
good chemistry yes those scenes okay
we're not gonna spoil no spoilers yes
but you guys it's gonna be good yeah get
hyped
and then next on the dock it is what i'm
dressing for the school for good and
evil
this is real forever
it's real ah
for wonder it really is our outfits look
at that dress
bring it back
we got it yeah you ever wonder guys this
is
live it is where every great fairy tale
begins charlize is everywhere lately
i want it i want her to be in everything
she's making so many cameos and just
become villains giving traffic i want
her yes
i want her to make a cameo in my life
she's so gorgeous
she's so
[Music]
the
tiny
though i know i love that like
oh they're so beautiful
bird
intense bird what is that bird is so
intense
as someone who has an actual phobia of
birds no that is my nightmare oh no like
i live in new york right now
me and the pigeons have like gang
warfare it's really not not okay
but this i love these books and i am so
excited that it's finally being adapted
it's been like in the works for years
and the casting is perfect i looked at
the catholics they got everyone patti
lupone is in this i
i'm living yeah this is gonna be a
delight a treat they're doing it right
they really are it's it's always the
best when the creator can be so involved
like soman is so involved and he loves
it it's like his baby coming to life and
you can tell that he's so proud and so
happy yes and i think the delight of
having it made now is that you can have
like even more diversity than in the
actual like i love the casting for
agatha i love everything that's going on
with it and like we haven't had some
fairy tale stuff in quite a while
bring it back so i'm excited that we're
gonna have like this kind of like more
deconstructiony but still fun you know
we can have we can have both uh-huh
we want more
please
i do i want so much more give me more
fantasy all of it i will eat it up i
will eat it all up princesses princess
okay next i'm here
she's right here she's right in front of
me
so next is the thing that i'm really
hype about too sandman because i'm a
neil gaiman stan and uh i can't we all i
love this batman
talk about a hottie
dreams yeah
honey
you know too many robes can always lead
to disaster yeah you gotta be careful
when you summon stuff
look at that code oh yes companion i
wonder
i was like did she steal it from the
doctor she was like she's like it's my
turn now i've watched too many trench
coats i want to wear one
story
don't shoot the naked man
oh
yeah yeah
that's the show
of the palace fire i don't know i want
someone to call me fire oh is that on
your wishlist
he's free
he's out of this cage
[Applause]
come in out of my cage i'm doing just
fine oh
another bird somebody sorry the agenda
so that is the bees the birds and bees
are on the netflix salary it's so
hardcore um and the news just dropped
recently i think it just dropped the
other day that mark hamill is going to
be voicing one of the characters in this
pumpkin head i'm so excited for this
okay you know that i can't stand luke
skywalker but i love mark hamill as a
voice actor he is incredible he is the
most incredible voice actor so i am so
excited the impact he's had on like
generations of childhood unmatched of
course like
seriously i cannot wait for this
i'm so excited did you read the sandman
comments i am in the process right now
i'm having my first time and it is
overwhelming in all of the best ways i
i'm obsessed i just can't wait and
there's so much more to come i know it's
it looks so good as someone who like has
seen neil like bring so many different
works to life i feel like he this is
like seeing his vision come alive in a
whole new way it looks fun it looks
engaging it's bright i can see
everything it's not in dark dreary
undertones so i'm excited about this i
can't wait for more sandman same
i need it oh so good and what do we have
next on the docket test well next
actually i think you should do this one
because you were really excited about
this yeah masters of the universe
cause she just kept bringing it up over
and over again
i'm like girl this is yours take it away
i didn't even know this was happening
and i was like
surprised
surprise [ __ ]
we got you
oh
revolution
revolution
oh it looks so good i
crown skull daddy sword that's all i
need
i'm
so excited you guys like
tell me why tell me why princess because
like so
the netflix has been doing we're between
shira and what chemistry did with the
other masters of the universe like it's
so rich and like we had lena haiti
muscle out
powerful figure it was just perfect i i
love this universe i love that we're
going to have more of it that it's going
to keep expanding and it's going to keep
surprising people yeah i think so many
people came into both with such a like
pre-established idea and
all the creators and noel and and kevin
would be able to just like just switch
everything so i'm just really excited
for that and
uh it's amazing i mean i just love
animation so i'm always down for
anything animated what is the chat thing
about anything that's been going on i
wonder what they're thinking how they're
living let's see let's look at the chat
who's your favorite character on the
show which show i don't know i just says
on the show i think we can just pick any
of the shows that we just looked at
because we haven't looked at the chat
because we've been bad
we've been naughty sorry
we're so good in evil i think i think if
we go to umbrella academy that's a good
one because there's a lot of good
characters i love five because five is
like the best he's just this old man and
his baby body just like my siblings
won't listen to me
i keep telling them apocalypse is coming
and they just don't listen so i love
five five is great i love klaus
oh my gosh
he's so chaotic
it's hard they're they each one of them
have like their own like positives and
negatives so yeah it's difficult and i
love him because klaus i've been
following that actor since he was on
misfits
real ones no and like he is just being
able to channel so much chaotic energy
i just fall in love with him every time
i'm like oh there it goes again there he
goes oh look at this look at him and
there's so many layers to his character
every time so yeah
those are definitely my faves of the
umbrella academy but they're all great
they are and they're great together i
like when they have scenes together and
riff off each other and they really have
that sibling energy which just it lives
up to everything it is and next we have
the return of an icon
wednesday oh
goodness goodness
please
i love the addams family who does it
right
stupid people no offense if you hate it
but
actually you should be offended
i think i have that dress actually
cosplay
i love it
tim tim tim burton
and wednesday like you can't go wrong i
really this was meant to be it was and i
feel like we've been having like a
resurgence of adam's family content yes
and i'm just so excited and also jenna
ortega great in scream i saw i saw her
in scream she was fantastic i just love
her so much and i'm so excited to see
what she brings in this character she
looks phenomenal she's an incredible
actor so yeah i just and
the thing
i
i'm obsessed i need more and we
i just like spooky shows and it'll get
me in the vibe so it's just going to
make me so happy in the fall when i'm
watching i can't wait what is it do we
have any any thoughts we're trying to be
better about the chat this time
wednesday is a mood wednesday is a mood
a big mood i my forever mood forever and
i think you know
i don't do you know who's cast as gomez
and morticia i have no clue do you i
don't oh oh my gosh
who's gonna be her sexy sexy parents i
don't know couple goals honestly anyone
i just i can't wait if there's enough
hot people i feel like they can find
someone they'll find the most part it's
gonna be so good yeah we're good and
then next we have the imperfects okay
which i am coming in wrought at this i
have no idea i am we're both raw baby
we're raw tonight
love you
[Music]
okay do you remember doctor sarkoff
doctor all of us without our permission
okay
oh keep closed
is that the one point one piece boy
tilda
oh i know
oh no are they experimenting again
we know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
imagine like here's your child he
they're imperfect
thank you okay that just blew my mind i
love that and i feel like
every generation we have like a weird
like dr moreau like what happens when we
experiment together doctors are always
experimenting they like please stop what
is happening like haven't we had enough
like no forever aren't you aren't you
over experimenting actually no because i
love superheroes so i i want them to
keep experimenting i like super powers i
wish i had superpowers i always feel
like
there's a reason like i used to pray
that i'd be a witch one day and i feel
like the universe was like if princess
has power she will be a super villain
yeah and too powerful and i would be
right i really my moral compass is very
chaotic i would also i would like be a
hero at first but then one hundred
percent
yeah 100 like there'd just be one thing
i'm like oh okay sorry especially if i
could turn to like a chupacabra creature
i would be like you know what i am
hungry
oh yeah oh if i was a creature for oh
are you kidding me vampire it so chad if
you were if you had powers would you be
good or evil let us know let us know ooh
i think that we just saw is there
something popular mind control yeah i'd
be
that girl straight gaslight i'm i would
really
oh man you would be too too much the
mind control that's too much i feel like
i would i would use it for good girls i
would use it for a good
99 of the time would you that one
percent would you
i did for like dumb stuff to like sneak
into concerts get up free upgrades on
flights yeah but then you'd get bored
you know what i'm saying where's the
line where's the line princess so you're
the devil on my shoulder just be like
dude like i would
do it do it
just do it oh and next we have russo the
grey man it's russo time so many hotties
in one clip oh goodness i can't wait for
chris evans and his mustache
well first we have ryan
gosling's husband he is
also my favorite part about him is that
he was in young hercules so he was
playing baby
is america's foreign oh not there he is
you must i love when chris evans is evil
he's very good at being so good
he was so good in knives out when he was
evil you know
eat [ __ ] it's because he's a gemini yeah
i mean that's really good geminis can
contain multitudes yep oh no
i like this boy on boy action happening
right now i love that he's wearing like
these little like
i'll just throw these on real quick
it's like excuse me guys i'm barbecuing
like oh i have to go inside ryan gosling
every dab
oh you know
the stress
chris
like pumpkins can do it everyone else he
was walking on [ __ ] glass yeah it was
cool
right in america's ass
right in the ass
look at this i was just gonna say yeah
nice out reunion
oh
yes
oh my gosh oh my god bob
look at her she's got her bangs just
like yours just so
you love a bang we love a bang moment
oh wow that sounds the roosters are
great at action they are that's their
that's their right they got that they
got that because they know how to
balance like the humor because otherwise
there's just like too many dicks it's
just like running around and you're like
ah slaps men men yeah yeah yeah too much
so it's like when you bring in the
comedy when you add the comedy to it
yeah it's better and just like the
little stylized thing like giving chris
evans a mustache like that makes sense
like you know it's like this is the new
sweater the knives out sweater now we
have
the mustache exactly grey man mustache i
love it and next finally
cuz look at that stash but our final
thing that we get to do which i know you
love oh it's what you're wearing it's my
time baby it's stranger things time
just a tip
[Music]
i don't
you're being mean to the villain stop it
let's like actually i want to go back
and look again yeah yeah a lot of things
happen at once i have control yeah we'll
see if princess can control this a
little bit and pause
oh
what is that i like i love there's a lot
i'm just so like happy and relieved that
hopper is like going to be with the
troop because i like we need to rush
together there's too many everyone needs
to come together it's it's about time
you know what i mean it's like well i am
i do not have the power i thought i had
i do not have the power it's okay but i
do i love the scene of vecna like in
that little like glass thing like that
is so cool to me i love the upside down
so much i so the more that we get the
upside down the happier that i am agreed
it's so good it's so good
and i just i think to me like my
favorite thing about it is it's like how
much personality you see in every scene
like going from the beginning there's
like i i love this shot especially
because there's just so much going on
with 11. so i'm so excited for that i'm
stressed
someone's gonna die princess i can feel
it in my bones and i can't handle it if
it's steve i will be i'm gonna riot you
know i think i will be okay no
but
and happier and happier gamer news we do
have other things this was there a new
game that got released recently uh yeah
netflix released a new mobile game today
called point b
point b guys we're gonna test it out
right now so yeah we're gonna try it out
this is this is intense because i have
the shorter nails i had yeah i i
couldn't
it wouldn't work guys so let's resume so
what i learned i'm gonna watch though
okay
oh yeah i have to look up i have to look
at what you're doing
oh
yes
you got it you gotta you got it yeah
no no yes
oh i see
because you're making juice
the juice needs to be made and then
you're making juice because the kitty's
hungry
oh yeah there's
okay
let's get that all right so we gotta get
right here yep yep
almost almost
i swear i'm a gamer guys
she's a gamer girl oh
this game is harder than it looks okay
especially because it's like all touch
and i'm just wait wait and then tap
oh you did it
okay she did i would have never been
able to do that all right and then
oh now she's got all right okay
now we're cooking with fire we're good
we're good all right we got it i'm a
gamer i've got it don't at me
i mean you can but
oh that was a combo okay
i know we're just like sorry guys we're
just gonna play this the rest of the
time okay wait wait
damn it the bird needs to fly is that a
bird what is it a little birdie blob i
think it's a birdie blog i know that
there's a cat involved i want to see the
cake i know we're gonna do the trailer
after this yeah we're gonna watch the
trailer guys don't worry don't worry
we're gonna do that in a second just one
more time we're just trying to get to a
point okay you give up
no
hold on this is what happens when i play
why does it keep doing that i'm not
wait okay okay
i believe in you
[Music]
what is happening oh i paused it resume
resume
these nails are not it
no no this isn't happening
absolutely not absolutely not cannot
figure it out all right let me try i
just like this is what happens when i
play on my playstation 5 dumb [ __ ]
bragging not bragging but i'm like i
cannot all right
we need to practice we're gonna practice
we're gonna practice okay we're gonna
get we're gonna get the high score we
won this game
but
what we can do to like show you at least
the trailer of what it actually looks
like when you're good at it when you're
good at the game how beautiful it can be
because it will
we're flops we're big flops but it's
okay the trailer is great
let's pull it up
pulling up the trailer
we're waiting for the trailer
here's the cat
[Music]
does your cat like lemons as well
yes
thank you ghost
love you
we won't exercise our goals
[Music]
they need the juice
[Music]
[Music]
available now guys this is
this is available right right now and do
you know
that
okay princess i want you to tell them
how can they get this game so if you
open the netflix app on your phone which
obviously you have you head over to
downloads and there's a hidden row in
there for mobile games
and they're which is perfect like
there's no extra charge yeah no in-app
purchases or ads it's just part of your
netflix description which is like
legitimately fire that is the best
because the ads are so annoying i can't
stand that when you're playing a game
and then i click on the ad and i'm like
i didn't need that 99 cents to be gone
for sure no it's too much you cannot
deal with it so this is great yes so
this is out now today the other thing
that's actually out today which is
really exciting is first kill first kill
it's we've been following first kill
forever actually we went to the first
kill premier league
it was a event they'll pull up some
photos of us from there because we did
look very gorgeous
but first kill is this amazing new
we love each other
[Applause]
guys we're besties but seriously uh let
me tell you a little bit about first
kill falling in love is tricky for teens
juliet and calliope because one's a
vampire and then the other is a vampire
hunter classic obviously this is what we
want and that's what shakespeare wrote
when you got romeo and juliet
look at us
look at look at that lovely delicata by
the way i'm telling you we this was the
moment like we this was our oh look at
us so fun we do love each other a lot we
do we love each other so much and we
love first kill because we love vampires
we love it and it's
you look so oh my gosh
i hadn't actually seen these photos
since they took them oh you look so i
was having a carry moment and it was
just and you know if anybody still
done you i would kill that with my brain
with my mind control powers you also
looked incredible too though we were
giving like candy christmas yes ugh it
was our we were the
best queen of the prom yes we were prom
queens prom queens forever
look at us and so first kill is out
today and we get to watch the first five
minutes and react to it and we have seen
this like so many times so many times
but it just keeps getting better i
honestly the more that i watch it the
more like i like it more and more it's
gonna be a show when you re-watch that
it's going to be like a comfort because
it's so it is comforting it reminds me
of what i love about vampire y.a
it's camp exactly it's mwah it's great
you guys you're gonna all right let's
get into it oh we're gonna watch it
that's right
sorry not sorry never sorry for my
cringe
arthy's song oh we love this song this
song has been stuck in our head for
uh
[Applause]
so fun fact when we were limps
[Music]
our amazing producer kelly was the one
who found the original song and found it
where and we were like oh my god she
it's a piece of
vampire history it is it is i'm so glad
they used it i love imani she's so good
so good they're all good they're so
great yeah amani and is like kevin
they're so good
unreal
edward and bella
[Music]
so cute
it's like it's giving drama
and victoria schwab i've known her
forever because she's like an og
booktuber
and i've been following her forever and
i'm so proud of her and she got to write
the pilot
incredible and like she deserves it
deserves it all
i can't believe we're watching this
[Music]
the music is amazing the music is
[Music]
[Music]
i know there's one scene where they play
ash nico's slumber party which is me and
my girlfriend's like that's our song so
i was like representation matters
oh
me uh waking up about blood
sometimes when i first wake up she's so
sweet she she met her at the premiere
she was so kind so i figured out that
pills are making love
for the reason
if you are a vampire
thank you for that thank you for the
consent and the blood yeah what's your
blood type i have no closing there
typical typical millennials like i have
no idea i barely have health care so
it's like i don't know if i'm blessed
with a millennial
god
if you become a vampire you can also
have my blood if you perfect okay i mean
if i become a vampire i'll figure it out
i'll be like
you'll just have your husband do it
i'd be like
and i know so many like queer vampire
fans have been feeling really sad lately
because so many like really iconic shows
have gotten canceled i think first kill
will not only fill that void but it is
with two
like lesbian leagues
and i think that just by itself is so
great to see and also it's like it's
lesbian leads that
are in fall in love you know it's like
there's no drama yeah there's no drama
about their sexuality it's exactly
vampire on vampire hunter conflict
we like it and they're so sweet and and
she's julia is so thirsty
like every time she sees calligraphy
she's like i won't i mean that makes
sense which i
[Music]
she's amazing she's amazing does when
you work for me have i ever been late
that's how i want to dress every day
right i'm working on this me too
one day i too i just want to be like an
accent the horns kind of girl
[ __ ] with my parents that's also a
vampire
best friend it's your name could you
please remind ben that we have a
doorbell
ben is he knows
so good and like like i love when you
have a shirt that has multiple queer
friends like heart stopper it's like we
travel and pack we do we do it for
security and so that we can have
accessories at every time because
everyone has a haircut crunchy they
they're there for you yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i got got you got you forever
she's like oh girl yeah she's like i got
you baby sis much better sweet little oh
sweet little one day i am going to kill
him
i would never allow that
[Music]
i love this fog too this is
[Music]
that's right right now it's time to
drink blood
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my gosh guys it's out right now right
now please binge like honestly come on
come on the cast is amazing
great black show runner and like i just
the show filled so many voids in my like
pre-teen soul that like i really love
the way it all came together and when we
interviewed them for our podcast
um they were just so warm and welcoming
and you can tell that the entire team is
very enthusiastic in a genuine way and
that just feels so good to see
because some people aren't nerds they
don't get it and they don't but they are
needed they are
that we love we love them oh and um the
actress who plays juliet uh she's a
youth friend of lore olympus so uh
rebecca um rachel smythe if you're out
there watching you have a fan in first
kill i just want to let you know that
oh goodness okay friends oh well it is
time to play one of our favorite games
here on the podcast
fight club
so we will be putting two characters in
the netflix geeka verse against one
another to see out who comes out
victorious oh
man i'm pumped here we go and so in the
chat let us know what side that you pick
and at the end we'll see um who you
think is right what's the winner who's
this yeah who would win
um
so for this warm-up we have bethna
versus dream um
aka morpheus so who are you this is
the daddy's right here i know daddy
warfare what who who who do you want
tess um
i'm gonna take vechna okay i will take
dream
i mean it's one of those things where i
don't know if vecna goes to sleep
i mean when you're with him when you're
when you're with this the sand man i
mean how could you not want to get into
bed with that all that goodness um
but it's it's interesting because they
both have like it's all about the mind
so it's manipulation of the mind so who
would manipulate whose mind right first
well how that means how would they warm
up i think that dream
would really like
because vecna used to be human so go and
go into the passive his mind as you used
to dream about
but vagner got those tentacles baby so
so you want traction you want to go
straight to fight so like okay so so
that's the first it comes down what are
we doing the first move i the tentacle
would come to distract
immediately to the throat and the first
thing would be
sand dust in the face
go to sleep swipe the sand never sleeps
[Laughter]
she can control
is like a millennial that just took too
much adderall like staying up all night
does not sleep does not how do you know
that he doesn't have any zoloft uh
that's true
we don't know what's in the option you
don't know what you don't know to the
upside down you don't know how
pharmacies or the doctors are so you're
gonna say you're basically gonna do like
win by tentacles win by tentacle yes i
am still convinced that he can go into
he will find a way to get him to sleep
go into his mind and make him destroy
himself i'm the king of dreams i don't
think that he's connected to his mortal
self as much so i don't think it will
work i think he's he's more monster than
man
he's become look at that do you think
that's a man that's not a man
i don't judge that is a monster i don't
judge that is a tentacle
just like dream he doesn't see gender he
sees a vector and a vector can go to
sleep that's what i'm saying what does
the chat thing is it all teams yeah
are we are we thinking vector are we
thinking dream what do we see here i
mean
a crete i think anyone created by neil
gaiman can beat someone from the upside
down uh
disagree
becno wins forever all right all right
beckner never dies
a real veteran never dies well
next
[Music]
to besties gotta go against each other
okay who do you want this time i'll let
you pick this um i'll do sophie i'll
take the blog
got it okay more fun i will be agatha
wait so you've seen the movie yes i've
read the book so we're coming it from
two different vectors of knowledge
different angles yes but uh so this is
difficult because i think you gotta head
up on me so you know a little more about
what would
you read situation
you know what princess it's sometimes
the the movie gets you into it so it
gets you into the fantasy and i'm just
saying okay so what would be the warm-up
okay what would be the first move
who makes the first well i think sophie
has mastered the art of being passive
aggressive
so the first thing you gotta do is neg
your best friend be like oh wow agatha
like
that's the outfit you chose i mean
it looks good on you
you just start with a little
psychological warfare ugh that is her
agatha's so good
would that even affect her probably it
is her friends oh
it's hard because i'm like in her brain
right now and i'm like oh no she would
be sad about that how would she react
i think that she would respond in an
honest way and be like what's going on
why are you like being you know where
it's like kill him with kindness kind of
like we're doing like passive aggression
versus earnest yes exactly it's like you
like it's like a brick wall but exactly
that is the best way like for trolls on
the internet if they say like a mean
comment to you just respond nicely and
then they don't know how to act i hate
that that's so true right so as a
youtuber i do know that everything is
like they'll be like
that's what you're wearing yeah do you
not like exactly that's how she would
respond damn you know that's a good
that's a good one a good like nice
response and then so then it makes her
look like the [ __ ] right uh
you know
you know what i was gonna i was gonna
fight you on dream versus becna but i
gotta say as a passive-aggressive person
i gotta give it up to you that's what i
gotta say that's how you win
also i do think that agatha would win
eventually because i think sophie would
get hoisted by her own petard as they
say and agatha would just be so warm and
inviting that she would have the power
of friendship yeah bada bing bada boom
also it's like when you're a little bit
of a narcissist sometimes that can be
your downfall yeah unfortunately i hate
it but
as a villain supporters
yeah as a person that loves villains i
see this happen to them a lot and i'm
like stop
what is the chat thing who between
sophie and agatha especially if you've
read the books like
this is amazing jinx would blow them
both up
absolutely yeah i feel like i'm over
there i am i am both the she's like
friendship
she's like i don't believe in school
and then um
i know we're doing cal versus juliet
well you know i'm p i'm cow yeah i mean
i want to be a vampire that's my god so
okay cal versus juliet vampire versus
hunter
warm up okay well flirting well
well that was a great thing because
we've seen the episodes so we know
exactly what many times yeah so like cal
would be like yeah sure just like very
subtly like this you know honey trap you
know kind of like yeah we can like hang
out a state can fit in meant well
actually you know what the one downside
about being a specialized female hunter
your things don't have pockets well what
i would say is that a stake in your
pants are you happy to see me
so how would you respond
[Laughter]
and then we would make out and then
then we have to fight in the middle of
making out yeah oh of course that's kind
like we would if your vampire could
levitate we do that levitating fight
thing where it's like that is the dream
making out levitation yeah 100
yeah but then i i would bite you okay
and i would stab you
kinky
we
never and
the bite didn't kill you mm-hmm
you know the buddy
the stabby was okay was okay dude were
you aiming for my heart um always
always always aiming for your heart i
think
what i remember i just be like because
i'm so distraught because the blood loss
has got me up
and so
and i just like weekly like walk away
and so we're like bleeding out of love
romeo and juliet our hearts pounding
with blood and just like as we're just
like we would just die on each other
that's the way to go chat what do you
think do you think
i think we both die serious about it i
definitely
the vampire wins no the vampire hunter
wins okay oh the vampire hunter has to
be really good are you that good yes
well cal is that good
we are technically this isn't about us
it's about it makes it personal i was
like how good would you be as a vampire
best family because i would be the best
vampire i'm vampire hunter d okay i can
get him hey
buddy
what do you think are you vampires or
vampire hunters chat who do you think
you better be team vampire and they're
gonna be like team team edward they're
gonna be like
i know they'd be like becna wins
they're just big mechna fans honestly
yeah
i think becca would win i don't see
anything in the chat right now right
that i'm getting
well i think they're just gonna agree
well let's walk paper scissors for it
okay
all right all right ready do you do rock
paper scissors shoot or rock paper
scissors
rock paper scissors or something okay
okay rock paper scissors
rock paper scissors
what
stop that
what is happening enough you're shaving
makeup we make out we might happen
too much wow we just had like a mind
mind
we did we just melted we melded for the
first time guys wow oh my goodness don't
be jealous
to your husband and my girlfriend
watching don't be jealous it's getting
hot it's our friend sure it is this is
the moment oh man this was this has been
so much fun it has i love this
geek week it's been so phenomenal i mean
there's just so much amazing content
coming out and to be a part of it
welcoming and to be part of all the
talent it's been so reassuring now i'm
the best for those who listen to our
podcast as they know we usually say like
one more thing that we're geeked out
about so in the chat let us know what is
the thing that you are like really
geeked out about your one lesson or was
there one thing in geeked week that
really you know what was your one more
thing that you're taking away yes you
know really
chef's kisses um what about you princess
what is my one more thing my one more
thing is that i'm just really really
excited for
the future of masters of the universe
like i love the animation on netflix has
been amazing castlevania
um
with masters of the universe i'm just
excited to see what more animation looks
like because animation is phenomenal i'm
glad that we've been seeing more respect
for voice actors god for animators i
really like it's a it's an incredible
medium and i love seeing it get
respected again it's money so anything
animated i'm so excited about
castlevania was one of my absolute
favorite shows so i am looking forward
to more of that a thousand i love that i
love castlevania i love that so much my
one more thing
it's stranger thanks
well you are dressed like eddie's gender
bank i know i just am eddie munson i'm
just like i was like what's my one more
thing i was just like steve steve steve
that's like my brain is just never
jonathan thinking about no i'm sorry i'm
so sorry i can't with jonathan i can't
do it i just like i just think of steve
and eddie steve and eddie together
steady steady they're going steady going
steady forever in my brain
um i just want more d
i want more
i don't want them to die i think that's
what i'm most i think i'm actually
stressed out yeah i know i i just i
can't deal with any of losing anything
july 1st i am going i it's stressful
it's a stressful thing but i'm excited
there's because it's so long as well
like the episodes are long four hours
it's long and amazing and i can't wait
and i can't appreciate it anymore yes
forever and ever please in the upside
down what is our channel saying about
it's time it's the point be time it's
time for point b forever i just love
saying point p u p
i mean it makes sense we all need we're
dehydrated we need juice as well
i know yeah we need some juice
i mean the tea has been
spilled just so spelt but yeah i this
has been so fun thank you everyone who
introduced chat and watching
i am i'm just i'm fully geeked out i
it's it's been a lot so i think we gotta
wrap it up yeah you know um we got point
b to play
we got so many things that we need to do
we need to prep our brains for stranger
things volume two yes everyone watch
first kill
first kill it's out right now and yeah
so we're so excited for like this but
like everything coming up next there's
so much more to come i cannot wait we
are we are so lucky that we are living
in this age right now like we are eating
the geeks are eating yes we have we're
gonna have gout by the end of this
lord help us and and geekwood may be
over but there's still more geek news
coming it is so let's keep an eye on the
geek channels this sunday at 9 00 a.m
pst because an exciting
[Music]
and we are so excited and also anytime i
get to keep working with you yeah this
really is my best we really are
we're wearing our fandoms but we're also
wearing our hearts yes for each other
love you love you love you okay so the
geek podcast is hosted by me tessa
netting and me princess weeks you can
find me on instagram tic toc youtube
just any of the internet places at tessa
netting
and you can find me on youtube as
princess weeks or on twitter as weeks
princess and make sure you are following
us the geeked podcast if you had fun
with us today search us for the geeks
podcast wherever you get your podcast
and follow us all right it's worth it
we're great we're we are genuinely
hilarious okay we are fun we are gay we
love villains and we're geeks and we're
geeks and for us geek week lasts all
year we have some great episodes coming
up too
cause like there's no reason not to
follow up yes in the coming weeks we're
going to be covering first kill umbrella
academy stranger things four volume two
and so much more yes i can't wait for
you all to hear them like
and also like
we go into it like yeah we are nerd
going into all this dive
we we will go there we go in deep and
we've been right about everything so far
we have we have
we are correct and in the meantime be
sure to follow netflix geeked on
instagram twitter and tick tock thank
you so much for watching bye
bye
goodbye
want to stay in the know about your
favorite netflix shows and films you'll
find news videos interviews and more on
taboo the official netflix site to help
find and fuel your fandom stranger
things the gray man the umbrella academy
and more make peak week last all year on
netflix.com